when I did the Grinch literally the  makeup was like being buried alive every  day and then Brian Grazer came in and uh  being the Fix-It man and uh came up with  a brilliant idea which was to hire a  gentleman who is trained to uh uh to  teach CIA operatives uh how to endure  torture if you're freaking out and you  start to spiral downward uh turn the  television on change a pattern have  someone you know come up and smack you  in the head  um you know punch yourself in the leg so  it was or or smoke smoke as much as you  possibly can so I was this Grinch  sitting  give me a like  and this giant cigarette holder so so  the yak hair wouldn't go on fire  it's horrifying wow it was horrifying it  was just like it's for the kids it's for  the kids